[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is our first year of bringing you
to the very edge
of your seats with the very best of what
video
very games have to offer an open
dialogue with fans is deeply important
to us
give us your hard-earned
money
[Applause]
old news this guy is you okay today
is only the beginning tomorrow's
unethical business practices today the
future of video games
and the futures future future
what an event am i right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
if i care
she's straight busted shut up morgan if
we can't get her mind right for this
press conference i've got
something back hello
this is real
this is happening
[Music]
come with me if you want to live
so wait that's the future's feature
feature so what's now the features
feature
uh check a look
this is a feature nina this is the
features feature uh
all right so what do you need me for i
need you to help me stop
them now so that then doesn't happen
what
say i need you to help me stop the
future's feature feature by canceling
the futures
future it's a thing trust me
[Music]
that's enough with the primping your
poops cheese and rice i just jack
punched a tur-willing bum duffle full of
shadow warrior three footage through her
cortex
that galloping fem gremlin is like nine
seconds away from flipping all the way
out
[Music]
whoopsie
[Music]
don what's our status are we set oh yeah
totally she's green across the board
online and prep to cycle the game play
reveal sequence in three two
one and hit it
[Music]
in the year of our sword 2013
devolver digital and developer flying
wild hog
rebooted the seminal 1997
slash nasty shadow warrior series to a
skull
thumping spectacle of bullets
blades and blood demon blood
then in 2016
shadow warrior 2 up [ __ ] the bar for
first person melee combat
and maximum next level ninja [ __ ] in one
of our most successful games
ever forever
now shadow warrior 3
is set to vault the series forward again
by expanding its trademark combat and
piling on a
[ __ ] ton of new additions like brutal
executions
thrilling annihilation and gorgeous
acrobatics
making every battle a new violent
portrait to paint it is time
to stop and smell the cherry blossom
and then cover those cherry blossoms
with buckets of blood
demon blood
ladies gentlemen folks
your first look at flying wild hogs
magnum [ __ ] opus
shadow warrior three
check a look
[Music]
roll it [ __ ] yeah right
well howdy stranger wang
where are you can you hear me demons
they're trying to break through the
gates i'll track you down
who the hell let you out of the circus
oh i bet that had to hurt
[Music]
stay frosty
[Music]
honey i'm home
[Music]
delicious absolutely boots and delicious
that's how you open a digital showcase
put my lifeless corporate shell
have it say some stuff doesn't matter
what the stuff promise gameplay
deliver gameplay season with a smidge of
unnecessary violence for the clicks and
serve can i genesis device or can i
zayn yeah how are we looking for the
rest of the show
we have thousands of people watching and
i want to shove so much fracking height
through their skulls
they bleed purchase intent bleed it from
their butts
gross this is going to be the most
incredible
effing e3 ever actually this year's e3
has been canceled
and while frankly it's a goddamn mess
out there with everyone jocking for
position
straight up power vacuum no ether you
say
nope huh
well he double hecking l with them
anyway i don't give a flipping freak
about stupid live video game events
they're dumb for idiots
the future's future is in super targeted
high concept digital showcases
and we're already all the way on top of
that
in here in her we're on the bleeding
front edge of a brave new world in video
game marketing
i've worked to sing years to get this
project off the ground
and with devolver digital protocol we'll
be able well
well what i'm not sure where you think
we are linda this devolver direction is
great
using nina as a trans inter-local
broadcast conduit or whatever is
definitely a stroke
but it's been a year so what it's been a
year
so everybody's doing digitals everybody
okay so
just in the past few hours there have
been five digital showcases
with somewhere between 200 and
350 something [ __ ] games announced
nobody can keep up with this there's
total market saturation
oh z people love marketing the more the
better the world runs on hype now
hype hype and nothing else do you think
people enjoy the games they play anymore
they don't they enjoy the years long
cork soaking cluster junk of teasers and
trailers first looks and reveals to
consume and dissect
it's the campaign every teasy boosting
little screenshot every butt munched
retail leak
the games themselves are a side effect a
chore really
people obsess over games for two years
and then in one sitting
they burn through it like it's a
gazooking for parking microwave pizza
yeah okay sure but these digital
showcases are getting legitimately out
of hand
their numbers have exploded executives
are doing them from home now
i don't know what the hell's going on
it's just announcement after
announcement after announcement like
things are being announced just for the
sake of announcing something
like ubisoft just announced an
assassin's creed set in 1961 rural
indiana
i watched konami do two full hours on
four new metal gear games during which
they had a surprise breaking event to
announce the cancellation of
three of them during the same live
stream
this is madness linda and it's on you
you started it with with that [ __ ]
this whole [ __ ] with e3 out of our way
i'll be able to broadcast the putzing
devolver boosting direct every bootsing
day
until these hoe dung po dunk well then
their dump poop consumers spend their
every last dollar on devolver games
and there's nothing you can do to stop
me you're on the bus or you're under the
tires
so either you queue up the next segment
or you get the frick out of my studio
whatever you say
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
1961 rural indiana stupid
margaret where are you i'm outside
outside of the direct
is that your bedroom it doesn't matter
this is meetings now listen we need to
talk
i don't know madge this is a secure line
it's the only way i can say any of this
if i do it from inside linda will know
or don will find out and then linda will
know
this is the only way say any of what
xena
i know how to stop the futures future
future oh boy
this [ __ ] again or she got the living
[ __ ] shot all the way out of her by that
disgruntled devolver fan from first the
past but then from the future's future
future that one time
nina advised a contingency plan she left
it in case something exactly like this
whole ridiculous marketing mega mess
would happen oh yeah
what does it do i don't have a single
clue she only told me that it exists
who has it and that it has a name what's
it called the volvo devolver it's a
giant reset button the nuclear option a
last-ditch effort it's predator
activating his wrist detonator or or
bellock opening the arc or bastion
yelling moonchild
why why is this a thing
corporate america is a dog-eating
dog-eat-dog-eating dog world zane and
she
was a dog eating his dog-eating dog in
the dog pile
woof it's an insurance policy against
usurpers it's a booby trap against what
you're talking about the directs
zayn nina saw the coming tide of digital
showcases and the rise of hype over
games
someone someone like linda was bound to
leverage that power
it's an insurance policy i get it yeah
so how all i know is that someone called
the architects got it locked up for
safekeeping the architecture we need to
get it
and get nina to announce it this
simulation is
hollow it's just words and hype this
thing the architect has it's bigger
than hype it's real
so we get the whatever it is from
whatever he is and we get nina to
announce it and then with that and the
whole simulation shuts down
but i'm in there i've got a meeting with
him exactly just now it was exactly 12
minutes ago but there was a time zone
mix-up
and then he got stuck on mute and the
audio got all booked and my mic was
picking up the ac and
[ __ ] the next segment
yeah yeah i got to go
i'm in there though if you really think
about it
anyway thank you yoshida-san for joining
us today our audience is super toads
excited about the release date for fall
guys and we couldn't have asked for a
better host for the news
apologies again i know we had discussed
having two
actual fall guys as co-hosts for the
segment but our
air quotes marketing director genuinely
had no idea that they eat each other
when left alone
i know i just my bad good news though
our beloved ceo nina strothers is ready
to go up on split screen with you
no problem linda these things happen i'm
ready to go i'm
very excited about sharing the screen
with nina okay guys we're up ready to
rock socks in three
two one and our next guest
joins us from tokyo japan mr shuhei
yoshida head of indy's initiative sony
interactive entertainment
he's got some news about the upcoming
massively
multiplayer party jam fall guys
thank you nina and my condolences to the
loss of the two four guys
that was scheduled to be here i too had
no idea
that they ate each other quite
surprising but they look
tasty actually
that's hella dark
yeah absolutely yes please the volvo
digital and playstation have some
exciting news to share about four guys
please enjoy this new trader that i
edited myself
no way really not really
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i was told this was a starring role
which it's not and that i would have
creative say which i
don't i did not agree to co-host this
thing i'm starring now i star
i am a star none of this co-host crap
listen red
this is a digital showcase there are no
stars you will be featured
hard these are uncertain boots and times
buddy
i'm not saying you're lucky to have a
gig right now but you're lucky to have a
gig right now
did you just my marketing team was able
to score a heck and big name as a guest
for you to co-host with
he looks good you'll look good
the rising tide red it raises all boats
i promise this will be the split screen
for the ages
i'm not trying to fight the thorax that
beats me here linda but don't think for
one red second this isn't gonna come up
when we negotiate for the sequel
did you just confirm sequel oh let's
announce that instead
done i'd spin up a carry-on two
announcement thing on it
my client is not directly or indirectly
by action or statement confirmed or
imply the existence of a carrying sequel
or sequels at this time
if you really think this kind of scare
attack you're going to oh whoa whoa
whoa
well that's a shame don do we still have
the coho style locked and loaded
look let's just act like professional
business people and do this
we can work out the little deets later
chill chill
let's do this holy smokes
phil freaking spencer head of xbox hey
there
thanks for having me it's a pleasure to
be co-hosting this announcement
oh man the pleasure is all the way mine
i
wow i had no idea you knew about my game
that i'm in
well the fine folks at devolver digital
invited me to announce the release date
of carrie end
and it's only right for the star of the
game to be here
[Applause]
i am so sorry
i'm a nervous eater and man oh man am i
nervous
don't be let's just roll the trailer
take a look at the latest
before you announce the release date
[Music]
well i'll be darned like an old sock
they put the actual release date in the
release date trailer video package
i thought it was going to punch to a
hook and then cut to me and
that was supposed to be actually me they
hosed me they absolutely did
you do the rest phil i'm street shook
shooketh no worries friend
carrion from developers phobia game
studios launches on xbox one
and pc and comes to xbox game pass
on july 23rd we can't wait for you to
get to play it
i mean default for digital is just about
as unprofessional as it gets
first with the cold latte and now with
this ridiculous
dumb stupid ridiculous hey can someone
disconnect me
we've got a console to launch i think it
just you just click on the
select video options from the dropdown
and i think it should yeah
you got it you see me now not unless
you're spinning
poverty no how about holy [ __ ] it's jeff
keeley
hey you jeff keeley yeah
you are the architect of course you're
the architect
oh wow okay
um so the baller land
you've got it right i do nina gave it to
me and said you might come looking for
it one day
i'll start uploading the files now and i
gotta go soon because we've got a big
summer game fest event coming up and
it's gonna be a good one but all nina
has to do is make the announcement
and she'll be in the driver's seat wow
okay
yeah yeah that's exactly what we need
i'm not sure i totally get it but but
i've got it
and we'll get it done you're amazing
jeff
thank you and nina i'm sure she thanks
you too
good luck out there you're gonna need it
holy [ __ ] zane i've got it i've got the
vulva lantern it's great
great that's great what the hell is it i
don't know
but what i do know is that it's files
and i've got those files and we need to
get these files into the announcement
schedule for nina to announce during
this evolver direct right now
all right send the files to me and i'll
get [ __ ]
what i got to get it to don if it's
announcements
so so that guy's a dick
cue up the next one linda there is no
next one i've been trying to tell listen
donnie boy
the future's future is at hand if i tell
you to queue up the next one
you flipping queue up the next one do it
linda these games don't even exist like
at all
and as far as i can tell devolver has no
arenas and games we have no intention of
making darn tootin done
don't you get it this is where it's
headed where it's been headed
this is the next level people want this
they need it
they're starved for it the games don't
matter anymore
just that we announce them let them have
what they want let them eat height
roll the segment done yo [ __ ] okay yeah
oh
yeah got it done and
i don't really want to do this doesn't
seem totally necessary
just do it fine
i bennett foddy am super duper hyped to
announce my next game
getting down with bennett foddy a
sensual
rhythm dance game featuring the hottest
tracks
from me bennett foddy and the sickest
dance moves from me again bennett foddy
are we done here
[Music]
don't think perfect roll another one
hi hello uh i'm gabriella
uh and i'm dean and we have nothing to
announce so thanks
bye well we have one thing we have
a studio called beans yeah this one
in toronto canada yeah yeah um and we're
working with
devolver digital on probably a game
maybe
yeah well we're working on something i
don't know um and we'll announce it
uh we might show it probably never yeah
yeah yeah never we'll show it next we'll
show it next year sometime next year but
we are hiring
uh you can check that out at
www.thebeansteam.com
on your local internet provider
so bye have a great year
oh and [ __ ] you linda [ __ ] you
yes again
[Music]
excuse me you're telling me to announce
that it's [ __ ] real it's okay just
just announce it or linda will kill me
literally sure okay whatever
hype this is sonic fox here and i'm
thrilled to announce sonic fox's furry
fighter 4
even though there's not very fighters 23
holy [ __ ] thank you you absolutely saved
my life sure
whatever you're lucky that game is not
even real otherwise mixer dumbass in it
[Music]
i'm not doing a bathtub scene for some
no mean publishers digital showcase
end of story i'm not getting memed again
yen did you leave the mega scope on
again
yeah no it's definitely working how do i
turn this bloody thing off
turn the switch where is it
damn it
[Music]
um okay yeah uh that was maybe too much
that backfired that was carol's official
what else have we got it was the goddamn
witcher
done oh yeah uh that's the list uh
we're tapped out mother loving butt
crumpet's done
give me something i'm up and i don't
want to come down give me that sweet
release
get me over the edge get me an industry
celeb
i i uh oh i have an uncle that works in
nintendo and no no okay that'll do just
bring him in here and spin up nina
i'm gonna need a minute okay uh
apologies in advance though
that guy is kind of a boxer oh god
what the actual i need you to queue this
up what no uh my uncle from nintendo's
up next i don't care when just
you need to get these files into nina's
announcement list why
what even is what even is this this is
way out
it's way out of default or direct no man
i need this gig
i i've got dental and [ __ ] she's [ __ ]
insane man
this is all [ __ ] insane
don oh zayn listen don's got this uncle
we're doing with nina right now
get back to your shiz let's get going
on it yeah
think about it our next guest
needs like zero point none introduction
you have heard about him
in your favorite forums on the socials
in your usenet groups
and on your best friend's myspace pages
he is a legend
to each and every one of us what have
that
real deal holyfield interest in the
video
and i am deep down proud to be the one
to bring him all the way to you
direct audience at home my
uncle that works at nintendo
hey yeah yo thanks for having me or
whatever look let me get one thing out
of the way first
you want to know the next character
coming to smash because sister i can
tell you the next character coming to
smash
no no not at all no this is neither the
time nor frankly the legally licensed
venue for that sort of announcement tom
nook is into the federal government for
over 600 large and unpaid taxes
and let me tell you something about it
he ain't got it hey this is really none
of my business and it really isn't what
you're supposed to be talking about
anyways
yoshi you know the dinosaur he did a
nickel hot in the stone he lonesome on
possession with intent
in the can they called him the mouth and
he ran a gang called the j cats
wait are you serious oh yeah yeah that
toadstool broad went rat on him for
immunity
now she would end up in the clink too
she's got connections royal coughers
big name suits whole thing was a
cover-up that dinosaur got rolled
yeah oh that's scandalous
what else he got oh sister i got a lot
a lot there was supposed to be this new
kirby game coming out this year that i
was saying
but he's all tied up on a canada divorce
and it ain't look like he's going to be
working anything but that alimony
anytime soon so all things all froze up
done like dead dead dead skis oh oh oh
uh pikmin battle royale fiscal year
2023. you didn't hear from me
fascinating what can you tell us about
devolver digital
anything we can announce right now
yeah check it hey toss that up on the
tubes or whatever
it's this game's called alia by these
guys what call themselves skeleton crew
what make games
it's hitting nintendo's switch and steam
this year and it is a gorgeous little
action adventure jam
with this crazy harpoon weapon will blow
your mind up
it's good it's really good i love it for
real
yeah wow unbelievable
my uncle that works at nintendo you are
the best uncle that works at nintendo
and the best part is you are my uncle
that works at nintendo
you know we should have you on every
year you know not happening
you're about to get a c d you ain't
never gonna see me again in fact you
never saw me in the first place
this whole conversation never happened
oh well
so
be
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and you're also out there yeah yes so
are you that's how this works
did you get the faucet on yeah i don't
think he's gonna help
do you hear that i hear me about to
drink my way through this lame ass
presentation
[ __ ] yeah what is that
it sounds like oh
[ __ ] balls i'm sorry i'm late i
literally ran
all the way from 2013 together no
problem no problem
i'm guessing this is about sirius
samford yeah yeah
i have a trailer here and a release date
for this what is this some kind of
internet presentation or something we
already have the release date champ
you're later than you think
it's launching in august and everyone
already knows [ __ ] me
did some walmart in canada spring a leak
again no no this is all about board
stuff
code team announced it two months ago
[ __ ] yeah okay
i guess that's cool or whatever i've
only i've only been running for
seven [ __ ] hey you guys mind if i pop
a squat
these dogs are uh
i was an explorer once captain sam
stone of the surveyor it was good
hell it was awesome
the truth is they don't care about who
we used to be or
what we wanted to do but they thought
this was gonna be easy
they came to the wrong [ __ ] planet
[Music]
okay old news but super good news
don let's tie it up something big give
me a closer
i need something marshall actually ma'am
shut up madge yeah no the uh the uncle
from nintendo was our ace in the hole
we are yeah we're out of announcements
for this year are you sure about that
yeah dude super sure gosh frazzling
shooter sugar freaking bull hot sucker
[ __ ]
you are the worst on the absolute [ __ ]
bundle deck looking worst hey it's not
my fault we can't end on an indie game
we can't end on your putzing uncle
give me something all the way great and
give it to me now
[Music]
oh hey i got something should be good
the future of video games and the
futures future
future
it evoked real actual change
dad
once a year every year
for years now you
dumb [ __ ] consumers with more disposable
income than common sense
have gathered around to listen to actual
powerful people like me
tell you what to like
what to get excited about and most
importantly
what to buy
you stare dumbly at your screens
drooling waiting for instructions you
beg for unsubstantiated leaks
cheaply orchestrated hands-free demos
you
suck down first looks without even the
slightest
thought for what is a real thing in real
life that you can actually have and
really interact with
enough enough
with the [ __ ]
you have been had rooked
gamed bamboozled jake you have been
taken for a ride on a bus
driven by greed and you have paid for it
with your
own super hard earned cash
you deserve better
we deserve better
and i am here to give it
right the [ __ ] to your faces
that is right you
slack jawed stacks of video game
backlogs
devolver digital is proud to announce
[Music]
i am proud
to announce the first
ever playable video game
experience that takes all
of the in your face stink and discomfort
talk and circumstance of a high
rent crowded convention hall packed full
of
all of us [ __ ] and packs it all up
into what we
really really really should be
interested in anyway
an actual playable video game
you can actually video game play as a
video game when we actually release it
for you
to video game play right
now holy [ __ ]
you guys it is
devolver land expo
[Music]
the convention center is now closed
please making
you are not welcome here exhibitor
merchandise is
all limits your curiosity
[Music]
[Music]
you received
so much
[Music]
so there you want meaningless marketing
hype
have it but have it as a video game
because really that is what all of this
[ __ ] is about in the first place
devolver land expo is available now
now now now go get it
free of charge on steam and dive face
first
into the future of video games and the
future's future future
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
and we all want it all
[Music]
[Applause]
to win
[Music]
when it all
[Music]
we need
[Music]
we're good enough again
[Music]
when the crowd can't hear your bite
get on a mic take a breath open up and
feel it
you gotta move
through the paintings play the game
[Applause]
[Music]
what's next
the future
you